Pat forty covers college football
college basketball for Yahoo Sports is
most recent column how Brian Kelly
reinvented Notre Dame to reclaim
national relevance we'll get to that in
a moment
what did you make of Ohio State's
performance against Michigan and how
will that affect the voters dazzling
performance by Ohio State atrocious
performance by Michigan it certainly
makes it I think an interesting argument
for a potential Oklahoma Ohio State
fourth place
debate in the playoff if you assume that
Alabama beats Georgia and perhaps Knox
Georgia out of that picture some people
might make an argument for two loss
Georgia right you know if Ohio State
backs up that huge performance by
blowing out northwestern which isn't by
no means a great team but still if they
go give the committee something to think
about coming in on just a huge role
they've got a chance to get the fourth
spot I still would put Oklahoma ahead of
them but they're gonna have B in the
argument Notre Dame is gonna play for
the championship or at least they're
going to be in the Final Four
wasn't easy at USC what did you make of
that performance by Notre Dame yeah I
think there was a little bit of a puck
eration going on in the first half of
that game no us think came out with a
great game plan playing fast and loose
and getting after it and they felt a
little pressure but they didn't buckle
under it unlike Michigan which I thought
felt the pressure and completely buckled
Notre Dame hung in there and finally
turned around got things going their way
and it was you knows the way they played
really all this year they'd never been
behind by 10 points before but they did
enough to win they haven't been dominant
like Alabama has or like clemson has but
they've been consistently good enough
and given where the program was two
years ago when that played in the
Coliseum when they were finishing a four
and eight season to be where they are
now it's a pretty remarkable reclamation
project by Brian Kelly what do you make
of clay he'll come back as usc's head
coach you know kind of thought that was
coming Saturday night after talking to
some people they you know they
craving continuity there they want to
give him another chance
his record was really good with Sam darn
old it's been really bad without it uh
you know I'd say this I never thought he
was a very good hire I never thought
Lynn Swann was a good hire as an
athletic director those two have now
married themselves to each other the fan
base has checked out fans are done
they didn't even never even put 60,000
in the Coliseum all year and the fan
reception that I saw to clay Helton was
not good at all and that was before they
lost and before they retained it yeah I
had heard that they had a short list
here if that wasn't that move was gonna
be made and then I was told you know
that this might be clay Helton and Lynn
Swann who were both together as a
package deal and you know not nobody's
guaranteeing anything after next year in
this situation mm-hmm right I think so
you know I mean Swann kind of got
himself into this predicament by
extending Felton when he really didn't
have to but that's what athletic
directors do they're bad businessmen by
and large and so you know they he cuffed
handcuffed him to a gun to a 20 million
dollar buyout and so he's kind of stuck
with clay Helton yeah we'll see what
happens next year they got a young
talented quarterback with some young
talent around him you know if they take
a big step forward this can all be okay
but I I have a feeling that the fan base
is gonna have a hard time coming back
around to clay Helton for another year I
was at the Ohio State Michigan game and
not that you could glean anything from
watching Urban Meyer but I did see video
of him after the game sort of collapse
into his wife's arms and you know a
prolonged hug there that it just it
feels different there I don't know what
this means bigger picture with Urban
Meyer and maybe I'm reading too much
into it but as I said six weeks ago he
just doesn't look healthy on the
sidelines I don't know if he's enjoying
this at all
I agree across the board you know
whether it's physical whether it's
mental it's emotional whatever I don't
think this has been an enjoyable season
for him at all a lot of that is
self-imposed self-induced but yet does
he want to keep doing this really is the
question we won't know for a while and
now
you know you beat your butt rival and
score 62 points on them well maybe your
head feels better I don't know but it's
it's been a struggle it's been a strain
it's been uncomfortable at times
watching him you know I'm reasonably
confident there are pretty serious
internal discussions of like do I really
want to keep coaching you know is this
something I'm physically able to do so I
you know I think that he's got a
decision to make
you know that decision may be delayed
given if they're gonna end up going to
the playoffs but if if they don't end up
in the playoff perhaps we will have some
sort of clarity on Urban Meyer you know
going forward into 2019 sometime between
the Big Ten championship game and
whatever bowl game they plan let's look
ahead to next weekend what do you think
happens you know I think it's gonna be a
really good game in Atlanta
I think Alabama Georgia Georgia looked
Alabama's 114 get straight games 13 of
them blowouts one of them they were
staring defeat squarely in the eyes and
somehow escaped and that was against
Georgia this Georgia scheme I don't
because it's good but I think I could
enough to give him a battle I expect
Ohio State to win I expect Oklahoma to
win but I think that's gonna be a good
game Red River you um so you know I
think the way it shakes out obviously
Notre Dame's in the clubhouse Clemson is
gonna be in easily Alabama even if they
lose is going to be in but let's say
they win and then I think it really does
come down to a resume contest between
Oklahoma and Ohio State who would you
put in right now I put in Oklahoma I
just have a hard time getting past a 29
point loss to a 6 and 16 man this how
does Oklahoma's defense I mean it's it's
horrible and it's horrible how is that
possible I don't know I mean but they
came here West Virginia I actually
tweeted I are there safeties on strikes
they were never near the ball ever it
was just unbelievable the back end in
the middle of it was just wide open
there are a hundred and eleven
nationally in defense they are the one
unit if you look at all the come all the
playoff contenders the one unit that
stands out is just simply awful
while state's defense isn't very good
but Oklahoma's is really bad
and I don't know I mean that's the one
big drawback for them now they've got
also got the number one offense which
means they could score enough to at
least I would think contend perhaps with
Alabama if they played him in a playoff
game but I think Alabama looks for every
single possession good stuff there Pat
we appreciate your time as always thank
you all right Pat 40 Yahoo Sports
national college columnist covers
basketball and football he was at the
Notre Dame UNSC game for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]